Worthy person comes to you
myth, a piece of information
some major news that demands
your attention. Do not react to
this news. Do not base your
actions. on this news until you
are sure that this has been
correctly transmitted to you.
Lest you afflict with harm, a
people based on ignorance, and
at the end of the day, find
yourselves in a state of
regret. The point here of this
verse is that we are to never
base our actions on
misinformation. We are never to
base our reaction. Or our
interactions with others based
on shoddy information. We have
to make sure of two things when
we, especially, when we deal
with other people. Two things
Number one, we have to make
sure that we are seeing things
as they are. Meaning, the
information is correct. It's
been properly transmitted to
me. I am sure that I am seeing
I'm sure that I am seeing the
situation for what it truly is.
The second thing is I need to
make sure that in my reaction I
need to make sure that I am
doing according to the command
of Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala.
So, there's two things. Number
one, I need to be sure that I
am seeing things as they are.
My observation is not clouded.
Things are as I have as I have
perceived them to be. So, I
need to make sure my perception
is correct. And second of all,
when I react, I need to make
sure that my reaction is
correct and appropriate to the
situation. Appropriate how. It
is in accordance with the
commands of Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala. It is far from the
prohibitions of Allah subhanahu
wa ta'ala. It not okay to just
react. It is not okay to harm
another person, to harm, or
even annoy another person.
There's a difference between
harm and annoyance. To merely
annoy another person. Whether
that be even with
dealing with them coldly. after
being warm to them. I'm now all
of the sudden cold. Cold
shoulder. This is a kind of
boycotting, ostracizing of a
person. This is something that
hurts people. I not allowed to
inflict pain on another human
being in any way until I am
sure that number one, I have
perceived the situation for
what it is and number two, I am
reacting in accordance with the
will of Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala. If I don't have both of
those things locked in in a
sense of surety. I am certain
of both. I have no right to
harm another person in any way.
Whether that be with my tongue,
whether that be with my
actions, with my wealth, with
my money, with my clout, right?
Maybe I I know a lot of people,
a lot of people to take my,
they follow me in the way that
I conduct myself and if they
see me cold with a person,
they'll all, in turn, be cold
with this person. I am harming
another person actively. That
is not permissible without
those two things clearly in
place. So, we will continue
tomorrow in